hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects Artistry act
we are here with a special guest on the
couch Aura kanikin who is flown all the
way out from Montreal to be on the show
thank you for joining us awesome glad to
be here so one of the rare things we get
to experience on this show is when we
looked at a shot and speculated and
guessed and not been able to figure it
out then we actually have an artist on
the couch who worked on it to tell us if
we were close or not today we get to do
that with rings of power remember the
giant wizard scenes that looks like just
a basic Force perspective but they're on
the same plane they almost look the same
size but they're not we speculated the
crap out of these shots we're trying to
figure out how they were done and I
think we got really close but I'm
excited because I think today you can
give us some cold hard answers on how
those incredible shots were done I'll do
my best because I remember I saw that
episode and it was you guys were really
close okay all right
[Music]
as I was watching this episode for the
first time the moment this scene started
I was like oh like I have the best clip
for this show because we've gone over
the other Lord of the Rings films
they've done effects with scale here but
the whole time I'm watching it I
couldn't figure out how they were doing
it until we started watching it on
repeat over and over and over and over
again you have all sorts of shots you
have shots that are over his shoulder
over her shoulder you have wide shots
that show both of them and there's ones
that sometimes don't show his face
[Applause]
all right so this right here that feels
like a force perspective shot slash
composite shot a lot of these shots it's
motion control so the whole idea is that
you really have to prep it in advance
and this is where the VFX the production
side you know Jason Smith in this case
they go through all the math and plan it
out properly you have to figure out what
the ratio is of height and scale
differences so you would shoot the plate
itself with the hard foot you would have
a stand in for eye lines all of that you
would multiply that motion control
camera with the factor you need and then
you're moving away the motion control
camera from the action with the proper
lens and you're doing another pass with
the scale difference and then you're
copying those in and there is a bit of
you know a comp work and Roto because in
the background anything screen right of
that middle tree is CG trees oh really
well for continuity because the scenes
before you had all the trees kind of in
the wind and moving around and then
they're kind of relaxed back into their
position so for continuity we kept those
CG trees in subsequent shots so that you
know nothing jarring moves around from
take to take the thing that really stood
out to me and I think the thing that's
making both respect how do they do this
is that effectively the compositing the
lighting is so perfect like it feels
like the actor was shot in the exact
same spot but you also like the hair
hanging down from the face against the
sky being exposed correctly and you have
like the light going through the holes
and the fabric in front of the shin
there that's something you would only
really get if you filmed that person in
that spot for the take so motion control
is a really ingenious way to do that
because I guess you just get both actors
right there on the spot you just have
your motion same lighting yep you have
the same lighting same depth same
everything and then you would have the
stand in as well a very tall standing
that would do the same action so you get
a nice reference of how the light reacts
exactly at that position yeah and you
keep any light coming through his
clothes keep it from his element since
it was shot almost at the same time with
those same lighting conditions you can
use the same kind of elements that's
great like whenever you can do that
whenever you can get your elements like
right there in the spot with the
lighting it's just like it goes so far
to making the comping so much easier
so that shot
but what about what about that one
though because that one's totally
different from everything else right or
it's the same approach though okay so
that shot I think our original guess was
he's in the Raw plate there and her
character is the one that is being
composited back in no he was composited
God darn it but his cape on the ground
well we kept the interaction of escape
with the ground oh so it's him oh yeah
but it's the same scale though no no no
no no no it's just worthy bring in the
specialty tiny wood chips
so that way when he yeah well the trick
is I mean the trick is it's non-descript
enough on the ground that you don't have
actual reference of scale of the
elements you can take some elements from
her scale and copy paste them on the
screen right and just kind of fool the
eye a little bit for scale oh darn it so
you're getting actual like ground
contact ground element from his take and
you're kind of keeping some of that
under his cape there yeah you want to
keep the way that the lighting reacts
the way the shadow is reacting and the
interaction with the ground you want to
keep that that's a great one yeah that's
a it sells its so well because then
everything like to his sides and above
him is now from her background but it's
just the ground that's underneath his
cape and behind him that's from his back
yeah that's insane that's the way to do
it
wow so it's been a while since all the
episodes are released but it's great so
we can finally look at some of the crazy
stuff in the end of this series there's
this huge battle between what I well I
think he's Gandalf Gandalf fights these
evil witches and it's pretty sweet
so a lot of times we've seen visual
effects artists really struggle with
compositing fire specifically when
there's smoke in front of that fire you
know the fire kind of like you know it's
it's hot white almost yellow you know
when it's like bright and then a lot of
times when people put smoke over it it
kind of turns gray it turns brown which
Fire doesn't do that how do you
composite smoke over fire without
ruining the fire looking hot you have to
treat it like a real fire when you're
creating that CG fire it needs to be
Overexposed like real fire when you
reduce the exposure it needs to have a
core to it it needs to have the detail
to it when you're putting all your
smokes over it first of all they have to
be lit by that fire so that they get
that nice kind of orange you know warm
backlight that's going to give it the
detail and by making it brighter that
way that's that smoke element it's not
gonna reduce the exposure of your fire
either so when you're compositing you're
working in a high dynamic range
environment the fire elements have been
rendered in the full dynamic range and
you're consciously choosing to have them
be Overexposed in the composite reflect
real life fire unless something then you
know pulls the explosion exactly and
sometimes what you have to do is you
know on shots like this we're going to
go with a fire that's a little bit more
Overexposed because you know you're
focusing for your characters and you
know if you wanted to choose to focus on
a certain element you have to take that
decision to go while photorealistically
speaking those fires need to be
Overexposed other times when you're
framing complete shots where your hero
element is the fire let's say while
you're exposing for that right so you're
reducing a little bit the exposure of
everything around it so you can see a
little bit more detail in the fire but
you start losing the detail in the
background and what's around the fire
because you're choosing to expose for
the fire
foreign
the hard part about the sequence
honestly it's everything put together in
the sense that this is all happening in
the same environment right so it was all
done on set so they built the whole kind
of this Forest set environment
surrounded by blue screen which looked
fantastic by the way and then what we're
doing we just added a little bit of
enhancements to the ground so that
they're not super flat so we added
additional routes of additional rocks
and more debris and stuff like that on
the ground we built that complete
environment in CG from scratch and we
had to be able to wipe from you know set
to CG version for any single angle we
had to have it in CG because the
environment were evolving it throughout
the sequence right we're starting in the
beginning it's a calm environment the
wind picks up so as soon as the wind
picks up it's CG debris flying
everywhere it's leaves in the wind it's
branches and trees moving to the wind so
those need to be CG and then at some
point we have to burn the environment
down so then this is where you know you
built it in CG so now you can put fire
through it you can put the Embers and
smoke going through it and then after
your done with burning it you have to
show a variant of that environment
without any vegetation where everything
has burned off you only have the trees
and the twigs and the rocks that are
remaining just all smoldering and you
have all the Embers and a beautiful kind
of snow of Embers almost coming down so
we had to be able to evolve that
environment from the beginning to the
end yes and that's like every single
shot is just a huge composite shot it's
nuts
hey guys whenever we record these
episodes I try to come up with a clever
way to do this whole subscription push
thing I'm out of ideas so just please
consider subscribing what was your first
big project you would say I think my
first big project was Michelle goldris
Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind
[Music]
is he Indian that's a very clever kind
of big sets you know having actors and
with giant cookies and giant jars and
and doing some clever split screens here
and there and
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah so you have Kate Winston and Jim
Carrey's characters and then you have
the mother's element as a foreground
kind of out of focus element because
everything else in the sequence seems
like it's just an enlarged set yeah
because this thing is real world so a
lot of clever rotos and a lot of you
know just moving elements around and
duplicating foam so some of you must be
putting water into the actual like tub
that they're sitting in yeah they're
spraying water in it wait there's a
giant hand behind Jim Carrey's head too
is that a prop that was a giant tan look
at a giant prop oh you're right
oh man so once again it's just another
Testament to when you work with real
elements and you're just putting
together real elements and there's not
there's no CGI involved you can get away
with a lot
come on
I'm always really impressed by paint
outs you just brute force it and the
better you are at it the harder it is to
see well some of these paint outs it's
not even paint out anymore it's matte
painters just creating clean plates and
creating an environment that doesn't
exist because whatever happens behind
that fence you don't have a reference
for it you don't know what it looks like
so you kind of create an environment
that goes behind it and then you mask
that out really all you're doing is just
revealing a picture that an artist has
made behind it that looks like it's part
of the set now how about this part where
they're running up in the street this
seems like it's really just a bit of a
cinematic psychology trick where we're
just we've introduced the concept of
this fence and now we're just in the
street and everything's in Shadow and
you just turn the light on it and
revealed there's a building behind them
when in fact like the only VFX is
perhaps a CG while it's disappearing
exactly to see defense in this in this
one the rest of is all plate crazy thing
about this shot is like that shot like
it hits I mean it feels like a big
budget movie shot in the way but that's
a shot that's super achievable like
anybody could do that almost in like 30
minutes just like with blender or after
effects or anything as long as you just
have the clever lighting and then it's
like the concept of how it's edited in
place that's what I love about these
types of shots when you're clever the
way you design these shots it's super
fun to do it's like when we're doing
that ping pong shot if you know Jim
Carrey going from you know one corner to
the other but every time he arrives at
the corner it's the same corner and it's
kind of repeating itself
but it was like working on it what are
some parts that you got hung up on or
that you found really difficult the most
difficult things were really lining up
sometimes Jim's walk cycle and running
cycle from one take to the other his
speed wouldn't be matching 100 so you
would have to Roto him completely out of
the plate for like you know let's say a
second so you would isolate his running
and then you would kind of re-speed it
so that it matches with the speed of the
previous kind of shot before the Stitch
yeah that was a huge challenge once
again another shot that if done today
it's not any easier
yeah maybe I'll just see it a little bit
faster on the computer yeah that's
basically going to happen faster I mean
yeah it's easier in the sense of yeah
there's less waiting to see previews of
it some elements of it would be a little
bit easier in terms of you know now it's
it's kind of easier and more kind of
straightforward to do a lot of scanning
and photogrammetry of stuff and doing a
lot of references and multiple takes and
stuff like that but designing the shot
itself and kind of putting it all
together would still be very tedious
whenever we have like a real bona fide
industry vet with all these like stories
and this background history you know
it's a really spicy extended react
episode and those are on Corridor
digital.com so yeah go consider
subscribing about a whole bunch of other
great stuff on the website I'm not going
to sell it just you get it extended
react if you like the show you're gonna
like it even more over there so speaking
of quirky artsy heartfelt film projects
by very talented people you also worked
on birdman I did yeah
the Birdman won an Oscar I believe and
it's got some really really interesting
uh single takes you have to have hidden
cuts at a certain point oh you don't
have to but it helps
a lot yeah we had I think from memory
honestly I think we had about a hundred
stitches on the film itself some of them
went up to about 12 000 13 000 frames
for one shot like for one take and then
we would stitch them together we used to
have different categories of stitches we
had obviously I mean the stitches where
you're completely changing kind of uh
location or camera you know you're going
from a dolly to a crane or something
like that so you have to have a stitch
to kind of go from one to the other you
would have the time lapse type stitches
when you're kind of changing from night
to day or from day to night you have
multiple different cameras you're
projecting one plate and then filming it
through the other plates camera and then
lining them up together and then it's
kind of like morphing but in CG there
were some shots where you're basically
the camera from a plate finishes here
but B played is kind of here they're not
lining up properly so we would kind of
project both plates and then create a
digital camera that transitions from one
to the other and then we had the
performance stitches as well sometimes
it was just kind of like within the same
take we would just switch out the
performance of the actors from one take
to the other and switch back
wow yeah
that one's good dude there was one big
kind of morph and Stitch going on when
the camera was orbiting around them at
some point we're going behind Michael
Keaton's character
come on man I've been I've been helping
Leslie get off book for like a month oh
right these lines are that makes sense
right right I remember because I
remember those vertical lines in the
back that needed to line up from plate
to plate so these oh so right here when
we went behind him there was a morph we
switched performances so it's that's not
like a hidden cut necessarily that's
taking a another performance adding it
back into that shot okay sometimes what
we would do is not lose the actors
completely so even though they exit the
frame we rotored them out a couple of
frames before and we slowed them down a
little bit as they're exiting so that we
never completely lose them out of the
frame you always keep a shoulder or
something on the edge of frame that's a
nice way to not have the the cut speed
so transparent so that's the thing with
stitches it's got to be so hard to keep
being creative how you're doing stitches
because so frequently there's like two I
guess Stitch tropes there's the
something wipes frame okay and then
there's the other one which is your
actor just leaves the frame and then
you're like oh well we're coming back to
them those are like the main tropes and
I can imagine it's really hard when you
start to go outside that realm of
different techniques you're really
richer man you paved the way for all
these other little clowns and then we
get into kind of the more classic VFX of
having you know CG Birdman CG Wings did
you basically do like a 3D volumetric
performance capture of Michael Keaton
yeah because we had to do the freeze
performance and we didn't want to do a
CG face per se so we went with three RED
cameras that were gen locked together at
a specific angles we had this
performance we had his scan as well his
CG scan so we were able to project those
three footages onto the scan itself and
do the face replacement like that
you see
this is where you belong even all of
this we we went to Manhattan and we
surveyed the whole place we had a insane
amount of just photos and references and
previous post viz it's interesting so
the green screen for shots of Michael
Keaton there there's like a white screen
too that you're using well what happened
for those is the whole thing was
designed on a previous right about how
Reagan Michael Keaton's character was
going to fly in Manhattan So based on
that we went to Manhattan to shoot the
whole environment with a camera on top
of a crane in on a car but the
cinematographer did something so clever
on the camera mount itself he put three
or four GoPros looking at different
places so as the camera was filming the
background plates he was capturing a 360
sphere of the whole environment right
and that's what fed the screens on set
for Michael Keaton so Michael Keaton
onset was able to see where he was
flying and where he was looking at but
at the same time what was shot in New
York was lighting him so it was kind of
the the ancestor of having LED volume
one yeah it's like oh yeah it's like a
really it's kind of like the first
generation of you know using footage to
light your actors and it was really
effective because you would get all
these lighting changes that matched with
the actual background plates especially
here you can see him he's going into
Shadow there's nothing fake about it
he's not graded to going to Shadow the
actual lighting from New York was doing
that right to where we were there's a
lot so there's actual footage yeah right
as you can see there's actual footage
behind yep yeah okay wow especially
later at the end of the the flight
sequence at some point he goes into the
a tunnel with vertical kind of shafts
that create light and you would see it
on him all the lighting changes and the
contrast changes it's this kind of like
very intricate clean thought through
work that almost makes visual effects
seem like not a big deal you know when
you look at this and you're like oh I
just
it's great yep it's like well there was
a lot of coordination there's a lot of
perfect elements oh yeah behind the
scenes there's a lot of planning a lot
of work
so I have a list of over 300 movies that
have been recommended for visual effects
Artistry act and it's great because it
saves my butt on a couple days where I
really need some good Clips please
continue giving us some suggestions down
below I'll go into them for another
episode here it's really really cool to
have a bunch of great stuff because I
can't watch all the movies I don't have
that much time so you help me out if you
want to see more work that Rodeo's been
doing you can check out links to their
social media down below their Instagram
their YouTube channel yeah thanks so
much for having me guys thank you well
it's fun fantastic thank you
[Music]